nobody likes hearing about climate
change it's kind of like Duggar family
molestation stories you find yourself
going why are you telling me this I
don't want to know this is it over what
if the media spent nearly as much time
on family meltdowns as it did on ice cap
meltdowns TLC would have a show called
19 polar bears in who's still counting
climate change also known as the bastard
that ruined weather as a safe a
political topic of conversation is
coming for you and you'd probably be
hearing more about it if only cyclones
were better at the headings
you certainly however are feeling it
halting drought in California record
rainfall and flooding in Oklahoma it's
so hot in Texas police officers are
repressing children's pool parties uh no
wait that's just racism the first three
months of this year we're the hottest
ever recorded May was the wettest and
carbon in the atmosphere has passed 400
parts per million last time that
happened humans didn't exist you know
what also didn't exist
Amazon Prime same-day shipping hey Brent
that's a carbon high-five baby whoa but
luckily for the planet the seven liters
of the over developed world have an
answer while leaders at the g7 summit in
Germany have agreed that the world
should end its reliance on fossil fuels
within this century within the century
ah huh so when they've finished
extracting all the fossil fuels and kick
the bucket it's a bit like a heroin
addict saying I'll totally be clean in
30 years your life expectancy is thirty
years full and ironically the country's
demanding an end to fossil fuels also
happen to be those who owe their
development to the extraction and
burning of them it's as if the Catwoman
started berating anyone getting collagen
injections they made you girlfriend but
we all know international climate
commitments are about as binding as The
Bachelor marriages so who will ensure
they follow through on their promises
they will of course cuz this time if any
of the g7 countries don't comply leaders
have pledged to unleash the reptile
living under the Fukushima die
she plant on that country but it is a
valiant effort one led by German
Chancellor Angela Merkel she doesn't
want to see the world underwater just
Greece yet in the US when it comes to
climate change there's not only denial
there's doublespeak obama has that do as
I say not as I do policy when it comes
to co2 the science is indisputable and
yet he just approved mining ten point
two billion tons of coal in the Powder
River Basin he also approved drilling in
the Arctic attacked Shell Oil has gladly
taken up much of the chagrin of climate
justice activists and this baby seal
take me with you I have no place to go
do you have HBO so why all the fossil
fuel greater energy independence
American energy independence indeed we
must cut ties to foreign oil from
nations who dabble in terrorism like
Canada but the president has yet to
decide on the Keystone XL pipeline will
he reject it or will it be the final co2
emission he leaves in the Oval Office
yes that's a fart joke